this capsule we will be reducing the
dilemma of exploration versus
exploitation learning parents
we have seen previously
our first algorithms
active reinforcement learning
based on the close parent programming
adaptive dynamics where finally we had
an agent who could take his own
decisions and action chosen a state
given in fact was based on
the current estimate of the sum of
rewards future hope actually
the money what is that is a
index that knows the environment
then his calculation that can make
the sum of future rewards
hope will just learn the action
who maximizes that which maximizes the sum
rewards future hope according to this
he's currently experiencing in relation to
to environments so only according to
his estimate of the transition model
and made it this approached to choose the
next action if an approach that
will say voracious or greedy in English
we will say that it is an agent who is
glee is young so major bad and
we say that because in fact in this case
also the junta will update its plan
so choose new decisions to
from what they consider to be
optimal now ie to
from the information that collected it
so far so in other words
it's an age and will exploit the most
possible information that has been
collected so far compared
to the environment so the information that
is troubled in his estimation of the model
transition and to make practical
voracious approaches are very rarely going
found the final plan for a
men's environment and reason
it actually only takes into account
information that is accumulated
until now and not want to do
account the fact that this
information there and only partial is
so in phase has consisted of jean the
not consider the possibility of exploring
a little bit more the environment for
just amassed more information
on the environment take it to this
moment website better decisions by
compared to the best action after a
makes an interesting parallel to make
here between just the next forest
it's an approach that will explore a
little more and the hill climbing so who
extends the local search war
we saw earlier versus
animated similarities so we saw that
the uimm climbing say we have a
function as what we want
minimize
if here we are currently at this
position there in our function the islands
climbing that will try to do that is to
this place so by a comparison to
left then right and take the
transition so move to the state
who is the best
at this position also because if I
successful here institute because the
liing simulator will allow to
make a transition to a less good
state to possibly afford
to align an overcoat optima
mountain species like those in
our function may be reaching
a better a better optima that is going
maybe be dense that if even a
global optimum so this is no longer the
same thing here is that we will
allow to take actions that
according to the information we had
now does not seem to be the
better to consider the possibility
in fact we are not the right one
information to make our decision
and that by exploring actions that are
not optimal
currently we may be in fact
discover that there are other actions that
they are better
when an example here on in a
environment we saw previously a
environment where we have a grid iii
paris iv and so we have an example of
the execution of the business cure
learning not reinforcement that
precisely was wrong and in this case
in state 1 2 it was also the
policy so the decision that
corresponds to that state corresponds to
winter the boss is to say that
ultimately this agency he prefers
go through here to surrender
possibly +1
when in fact the best policy to
take this would be our best
decision will take the twisted that would
to go up to finally the
here we would have less reinforcement
negative associated with going through these states
there here is actually what happened
it's that in the execution of
the algorithm possibly at 7 is
also the agent made the decision
to go do it the boss she led him
towards a reinforcement that was
was not 0 that was positive because
that eventually
policies to travel to an eto'o fnac
in operation the more we were very
high and therefore son aja do not know
that so he was tempted to take this
action because they appear
better but never tried to go
here up so to make a
upward transition to this state there
here or there politics bring him back up
necessarily positive and better
are future rewards hope so
we see it here if we look we will
measure that
we go through tests on which we
does learning
we see that if we look at what is
written here as being the silent part
that the difference between politics
optimal policy has taken so
that we never reach 0 because of this
because we never allowed ourselves in this
case also to explore actions that at
beginning of learning did not appear
not be the best so too
exploited to be voracious it goes often
led to plans that are not optimal
on the other hand, to explore too much
actions that are currently not the
better it could slow down
needlessly learning who
maybe in fact we have the right
information at some point for
take it and that enough information
to take the action that according to our
information is the best maybe
it's the best thing to do
so found this balance between
exploit the information up
now and explore to accumulate
more information this problem actually
that they would leave fundamental in
learning by inevitably and on
which there is a lot of research that
make a better decor easier
or in fact one can determine
strategies that are optimal sure that
according to certain conditions and a sublet
learn more I invite you to go
see the code of the huge bendit in the
resource book of energy in
practice so what we will do is
only for more complex cases
we will use heuristics the pocket
which is often followed is to define
a function that we will call the
exploration function so this is a
function that takes as input our
current estimate of rewards
future hoped for as well as the number of
once I find myself in that I have
visited the state in which I find myself
currently
and the idea of ​​this function
of exploration there is that she is going
artificially increased the value of
future rewards is so in fact for
the close relative pda
what we are going to do is that value very
young
will be based on an update where the
new value for a state s
I will update it from the
next formula where did I do here
there is that I added this part if
I applied my exploration function
on my current estimate of the
future reward hope and this
function there we could define
different shapes but often ski
used as exploration functions
it's a function that if the number of
once I reached my state s is in
does I go back a bit so here what I
gives in my cns exploration function
acquired the number of times the action has
been chosen for the state s
since I started doing
learning so that's my argument
nbc emma search functions this
case is that if the number of times
that I chose the state s
and while I chose the action has to
my condition is smaller than a certain
threshold that I have to define their very selves
it's a species different settings
so if this smaller than this one down there
I will return a reward
optimistic i call r + that is
so the father allows sakin so
rewards that almost certainly
higher than it really is
and if not if I actually reached exceeded
the threshold of the number of times I have
visited the state s is running the action to
this state I'm going to return the real
future reward hope they have
given an argument here but which are so
these guarantees that the action havas be
chosen in the state is at least n 1 x
who are getting stuck with which I'm doing a
comparison when learning cij
visit
obviously the state ace at least this number
of times there so that allows me to guarantee
that I will try all the actions
at least a number of times in
finally deceiving my algorithms into
giving him does not answer
this inspired photo that is optimistic by
report to the information that I have up
it's a way of controlling
finally my dilemma between
exploration and exploitation
this number of times here this soldier with
which I'm going to know will determine the
number of false notes I'm going to
to explore actions that
are potentially not the best
action
according to my estimate of the rewards
future s